Let's say you want to write a program
that wishes your cat a happy birthday.
If you tried to run this code,
you probably go this ugly error message.
No worries, let's search for it.
Man, it says no results found.
So I guess I can't fix the problem.
Just kidding.
Let's try searching more effectively.
The first part of the error message
tells you the name of the file,
birthday.rb, the line number where
the error might be, which is line 2,
and the name of the method that the
error might be in, say_happy_birthday.
This information is useful for helping
you pinpoint where the error message is,
but searching for these things won't
help, since everyone's specific file and
method names will be different.
Not everyone will call
their file birthday.rb.
Here's the more useful information.
Undefined local variable or
method and NameError.
These words and
phrases describe the error rather
than the happy birthday program.
Let's try searching for these keywords.
Nice, a lot of search results.
There are a couple Stack Overflow posts,
a link to the Ruby docs, and a tutorial.
Let's look at the official
documentation first.
Hm.
Depending on how much background
knowledge you have, this may or
may not mean much to you.
The language is very technical and
it doesn't really explain how to fix it.
Let's go back.
How about we try this tutorial instead?
Hm.
I think we found what we're looking for.
It's telling us that we use
the variable, in this case,
birthday, without assigning
it to a value first.
So let's go do it.
And we could re-run the program.
Nice, it works.